[Música]
o que fazer com que vocês obrigado a
falar um pouco sobre economia e essas
transformações
e é curioso que no brasil a gente vive
um momento meio paradoxal é por um lado
a gente sabe que tem uma crise grave que
pode voltar
ele sabe que não tem novidade pra
ninguém leva junto com superados pelo
contrário o brasil tem uma situação
peculiar e que se nada for feito as
coisas pioram quando se pára de fazer
reforma
dada a situação do país amanhã vai ser
pior do que ontem
a gente parou com essa agenda do fim do
ano passado
e não é à toa que as coisas estão
voltando a piorar
e quanto mais se demora fazer reformas
piores elas ficarão em geral as pessoas
me chamam uma vez da segunda fase deixa
mais falar deixa é é exatamente o
discurso mais animador né reclama com
taís reclama comigo
o o porquê isso nós todos sabem disso
mas deixou só de alguns números rápido
pra vocês não vou ficar só a partir da
negativa da história
os números é o brasil inter e seu muito
rapidamente nós envelhecemos três vezes
mais rápido que a frança e outros países
é muito rápido tem um grupo de países
está envelhecendo muito rápido nós
coreia
quer dizer isso que a gente passou a
admiração dos meus pais tinham em média
seis filhos por casal pouco mais que
isso para a gente é impensável seis
filhos por casal em média tinha vários
amigos com nove irmãos oito irmãos
a geração mais nova
vocês têm menos de 21 pontos sete 1.6
1.8 e média de 6 - 2 - de 2 significa
que a população brasileira vai começar
em colher daqui a algumas décadas
se você olhar o brasil da minha infância
era uma pirâmide com a base imensa muito
jovem chegando poucos adultos
pouquíssimos idosos
o brasil atual é o brasil vai um senhor
com barriguinha né
nem tanto jovens e os jovens encolhendo
muitos adultos eo número razoavelmente
grande idosos os idosos do brasil já
crescem mais rápido
o número de idosos já cresce mais rápido
que o número de trabalhadores
a cabeça quer ser mais rápida do corpo
de quem só quem sustenta os idosos que
ostenta aposentadoria são os
trabalhadores
a notícia que eu tenho pra vocês são
mais jovens é que se a gente fizer nada
vocês vão ter que trabalhar muito ano
inteiro para pagar a minha aposentadoria
daqui alguns anos mas muito muito tempo
e dinheiro
além disso ao longo do ano seguinte nada
disso é surpresa pra ninguém devia tomar
um susto neste sábado 20 anos que
aconteceu há 20 anos o mundo sabe se há
20 anos até que o mundo vegetal de
previdência anos 80/90 todo mundo fez
todo mundo a rodar a 34 a previdência a
gente resolveu que com a gente não é o
caso
enxergar é que a previdência não tinha
problema o que fazer pra gravar o quadro
nos estados de vários municípios
o problema é pior ainda porque a
aposentadoria do servidor público em
muitos casos é muito mais cedo ainda um
homem por tempo de contribuição que têm
carteira assinada tem salário alto na
carta formal se aposenta no brasil em
média 55 anos quando tem estrangeiro
falo isso com certo constrangimento
porque nem acredito em média
55 anos aposentado o seu lugar do mundo
tem uma idade mínima mínima que acima de
60 c mínima silva 60 média 160 demais em
alguns países a mínima 65 e 68 como 55 a
média de 20% menos 50 anos tendo setor
público então nem se fala
mas como é que faz trabalhou 20 anos 25
30 10 vive mais 40 está vivendo mais
não sei quem faz quem votou contra a
reforma da previdência que explica como
faz quem não apoiou explica
olha não apoiei porque eu tenho uma
saída bacana pra fazer isso tá aqui as
contas que eu fiz
tem um jeito de resolver
eu não sei o brasil gasta com o
aposentado japão gasta um pedaço do bolo
que tem representado um pedaço do bolo
do japão é igual do brasil com a pequena
diferença que o japão tem três vezes
mais aposentados que o brasil seja um
país que testou a somos diferentes do
resto do mundo
olha os gráficos não estamos
completamente errados o mundo tá tá
errado o brasil tá certo pode ser uma
sociedade que o mundo está tão errado
como desenvolvidos países que deram
certo em cresceu quem renda média que é
emergente américa latina que cresce a
todo mundo errado
ele está certo este eventual fórmula
ótimo
os estados em situação pior que o
governo federal
meu estado de janeiro não consegue pagar
folha de pagamentos porque gasto com
servidores aposentados grande do sul
também em minas gerais também brasília
também e rio grande do norte também tem
mais de estado que vão chegar aí nessa
fila vai andar
o que acontece é que é importante só
afeta a vida de vocês porque porque isso
significa mais impostos ou não não sei
mais inflação ou não não sei quando se
investe do ambiente disse
mas ainda é o custo de capital sob a
máscara conseguir crédito para marcar e
conseguir recursos
deixa eu dar uma boa notícia que vou
passar dois minutos aqui do hamburgo
disse que nunca reclamaram disso tem
outros problemas mas também tem um
brasil diferente acontecendo você está
aqui na quinta feira à noite para o dia
um tema com economia
eu vejo jovens empreendedores querendo
produzir
eu vejo muitos homens de negócio
empresas que não vão à brasília pedir
subsídio do chão de fábrica é ser mais
eficiente
a gente assiste hoje esse debate o
brasil velho e brasil novo debate é o
brasil do lobby do subsídio da proteção
da não concorrência do servidor da
corporação de servidor que não quer ter
sua previdência igual ao dos demais e
tem o brasil os empreendedores que não
quer brasília e quer ser exportador que
a inovar ea tecnologia desse conflito
está aí né
eu acho que vocês vão ganhar eu acho que
o brasil vai ganhar a nova geração é
diferente da velha
a minha dúvida é será que vai dar tempo
para a gente vê isso nos próximos anos
ou temos que esperar uma volta à crise
soluções de poção mágica para poder
acordar e de fato a maioria mudar de
lado ea gente conseguir enfrentar as
reformas para estimular a
competitividade
o empreendedorismo equilibrar as contas
públicas e um brasil que cresce porque
produz não porque é protegido às custas
de mais obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]
i